[Musik]
lokale
krank ist direktorin für euch ein
traumberuf
ich glaube da kann ich säge und ich
glaube es hätte nichts dass es mit ganz
vielen aspekt von mensch sitzt er hätte
und dass es darum geht dass man damit
bis kurz nach
der messe sind baumbusch
man ihn aber luft machen
seit zehn jahren ist anett keller
direktor in der justizvollzugsanstalt
hindelbank sie hat sie nach ihren
vorstellungen geprägt
[Musik]
anett keller ist chefin von über 100
mitarbeitenden
107 insassinnen aus über 30 ländern
verbüßen ihrer strafe im einzigen
frauengefängnis der deutschschweiz
etwa die hälfte sind schweizerin
[Musik]
das schloss war ein landsitz der berner
patrizierfamilie von erlach und ist
heute teil der anstalt
des militärs telefontechnik des
sicherheit
gestellt ist
für was machen die da
jeder mitarbeiter hier die mitarbeiterin
hätte ohne handy mit einer notfall knopf
und wenn irgendwer bisher fünfmal der
drucker und dennis innerhalb von einer
minute ein sicherheitsmitarbeiter
moderner sicherheitstechnik ermöglicht
mehr freiheit für die gefangenen
größtmögliche freiheit und die würde des
menschen das sind für anett keller
zentrale werte im strafvollzug
wichtig ist es für sie deshalb geeignete
mitarbeiter zu finden die diese werte
teilen und in der täglichen arbeit
umsetzen neuen angestellten erklärte die
rektorin die grundlagen
der lügt im
freiheitsentzug das feuer sind
fünf prozent
also 20 13 zug sind ist frau und in
zermatt
war ist der grundsätzlich of funk
stoffbezug es ist stoff für ein begann
es schaffte alba anderem oder das gesetz
aber
19h und der sinn ist das wenn frau sach
und das sind über rückfällig wird
das gesetz sagt dass die bedingungen im
gefängnis denen draußen möglichst
ähnlich sein sollen damit die
schädlichen folgen des eingesperrtseins
gemeldet werden
zudem müssen die menschenwürde und die
rechte der eingewiesenen geachtet werden
der leitsatz sich jede frau tritt mit
dem rucksack gesichter an fähigkeiten
und
abzocker sich das es schafft ich glaube
wirklich mal pro kopf im april so stark
nicht machen
die juristen der uni bern würdigten
anett keller mit dem ehrendoktortitel
obwohl sie keine juristin ist sondern
ehemalige lehrerin fahrerin
sozialarbeiterin sie habe das soziale
klima im strafvollzug verbessert und die
chancen für die resozialisierung
die gefangenen haben die pflicht zu
arbeiten
weil die frauen mitarbeiten müssen
weniger externe angestellt werden
die küche sei ein guter weil lebensnah
arbeitsplatz es deutet sich das so im
bereich
reinigung des schrei so dass
die chancen gut bestellt
gefriert
trotz leerer als wirtschafts praktika
wie der name ja so traditionellen denn
bereits traditionelle frauenbild fördert
und dem
wissen und praktische zwecke
das power nach lehrstellen finden
gekocht wird für die insassinnen und die
angestellten und manchmal für besucher
die sich hindelbank ansehen wollen
sieben insassen arbeiten zurzeit hier
der umsatz lag mit kuchen war das beben
auch schon
es geht aber auch momente wo ich aber
noch nie bis kochte salami und war
nachher umso erfreuter eventservice
traditionen er
die bildung vieler frauen in hindelbank
ist gering fast zwei drittel haben keine
ausbildung oder haben eine ausbildung
abgebrochen martin schubach fördert ihre
fähigkeiten und ihr selbstvertrauen
machen mit dem ziel
frauen wurden
mit logo erfahrung gemacht mit mama
sektor
familie flecken und wo felski futter
freitag selbst mancher fahrer ihrem
leben und meistens vorname und zudem her
ist es ganz wichtig dass sie ihre mama
bild korrigieren im asset
management
als mal
wo sie her es gibt ja klar stände die
mannen von rechberg wäre einfach als
mensch
der freiheitsentzug an sich sei die
strafe sagt die direktorin hier drin
gehe es nicht um strafen vielmehr sei
gegenseitige respekt die grundlage von
allem die atmosphäre ist entspannt
das sind immer menschen und die der
funktionieren
ständig ist
die muttergottes in der zelle von
claudia hängt neben einem kampfsportler
wrestling mark die 24 jährige die wegen
eines gewaltdelikts sitzt opfer war ihr
damaliger freund er hat überlebt beide
seien sie kokainabhängig gewesen die
beziehung geprägt von gewalt menschen
man hat einfach im affekt gehandelt
was im nachhinein einem erst bewusst
geworden ist da ich in einer beziehung
war die sehr toxisch war
auch mein exfreund peiniger mir
gegenüber war und chemie wasser damals
die liebe auf den ersten blick er ist
bekannt als frauenschläger und ja denken
sie oft da die danach was sie getan sehr
oft ich habe auch immer noch große
schuldgefühle
das wird sich auch noch lange ziehen und
es wird man auch nie vergessen können
was da geschehen ist aber mir hilft es
sehr gut ich mache jetzt seit anfang
januar eine therapie die auch direkt
relevant ist und das unterstützt mich
sehr gut und ich kann ich kann es besser
aushalten also
schon
ihre mutter sei alkoholikerin der vater
habe die familie früh verlassen niemand
kommt sie besuchen dafür habe sie im
gefängnis seine freundin gefunden
claudia sieht hindelbank als glücksfall
sonst wäre ich wirklich als drogentote
irgendwo im graben gelegen also bei mir
war es richtig schlimm und für mich war
es so die letzte chance einfach auch an
mir zu arbeiten und mein leben wieder
auf die reihe zu kriegen also von der
mir
nicht aufgeben sich selber wertschätzen
lernen das ist für sie harte arbeit
claudia hat aufgeschrieben wie schlecht
sie von sich denkt ich bin ein fehler
ich habe es nicht verdient zu leben mich
liebt sowieso keiner und wie sie lieber
denken möchte jeder mensch hat defizite
deswegen bin ich kein defizit ich habe
es genau so verdient zu leben wie jeder
andere mensch meine familie liebt nicht
so wie ich bin
sechs jahre muss sie absetzen zwei davon
hat sie schon
ein drittel der frauen sitzt wegen
gewaltdelikten je ein drittel wegen
drogen sowie eigentums und
betrugsdelikten manche sitzen monate
andere jahrelang auf unbestimmte zeit
sie leben in sieben verschiedenen
wohngruppen mit abgeschlossenen
außenräumen sowie gemeinsamen
aufenthaltsräumen in denen sie sich
tagsüber frei bewegen zusammen essen und
auch selber kochen dürfen wenn sie
möchten
sie arbeiten in der hauswirtschaft was
machen sie da genau
ich schaue dass alles ordentlich und
sauber ist sodass es ist wie ein
richtiges zuhause
die ehemalige jus studentin muss nur
wenige monate absitzen
für mich ist es wie ein universitäts
campus wir arbeiten aber wir haben auch
die chance etwas zu lernen und es gibt
freizeit man kann sport treiben es gibt
sogar eine theatergruppe
wir haben viele möglichkeiten deshalb
fühlte sich schon ein bisschen wie ein
zuhause an
pasadena lüthi von kuscheljustiz ritter
das edi wasser und brot macht mit
besseren menschen da ich selbst und und
wichtig ist aber unser auftrag ist im
gesetzlichen auftrag ist das leben in
der vollzugsanstalt möglichst
gestaltetes leben und da costa brava das
dritte gruppe leitet das frauchen
schaffen dass sport machen sechs hunde
amerika sehr gute gesundheitsvorsorge
bild ich sagen wollte und da ist denn da
wo so wirkt wie die haben so ganz
schöner innen aber da steckt sätzlich
auftrag mit sicherheitschef könne da sie
arbeitet anett keller seit zehn jahren
zusammen er war
sicherheitsverantwortlicher beim
eishockey-club spiel und hatte die
hooligans in schach gehalten sie hat ihn
angestellt weil ihr ihre überzeugung
teilt das prävention sicherer sei als
repression dynamische sicherheit heißt
das konzept früher seien sie belächelt
worden heute sei es standard mit seiner
show basis schafft das denn wenn es
auseinandersetzungen geht quasi die für
ohne dass die
armee heißt es ist eben schwieriger wenn
nach op tisch mit stuhl was ist besser
wenn du mit opera schrott
wunsch und macher vierte resultat
dass da wirkt es so
und dazu auch und das respekt und
freundlichkeit trust corp
sie haben den lift nehmen wollen statt
die treppe sagt rochester schnelles geld
verdienen mit drogen die studentin war
24 als sie verhaftet wurde in den
monaten der untersuchungshaft ging es
ihr sehr schlecht hier im vollzug sei es
besser aber es bleibe eine künstliche
welt
dass du keinen kontakt nach draußen hast
ist sehr schwierig das leben geht vorbei
an dir vorbei vorbei
denn du bist kein teil der welt mehr du
bist ein gesperrt
es ist ein leben ohne handy ohne
internet sie ist froh dass sie bald
rauskommt
seit 60 jahren gibt es die mutter kind
abteilung bis zu sechs kinder können
hier mit der mutter leben bis das kind
drei jahre alt ist
in dieser zelle lebt eine frau mit ihrem
anderthalbjährigen töchterchen tagsüber
geht die kleine in die kinderkrippe im
dorf während die mutter im gefängnis
arbeitet ihr drohen vier jahre haft und
sieben jahre landesverweis zwar ist sie
in der schweiz geboren und aufgewachsen
hat aber keinen schweizer pass die junge
frau klagt die vorstellung sich von
ihrem kind trennen zu müssen
[Musik]
für
einmal schwieriger entscheid und simyo
entscheid wo
ja trotzdem schwierig sind
die frage ist trennung von anfang an
oder erst wenn das kind drei ist die
betreuerin sagt es gebe viele gründe
warum mütter straftaten begehen
also ziemlich brasilianer
noch nie kran mit dem kriegen
drogentransport gemacht hat
und ja ich kann mir vorstellen wie man
mit welchem es liege nahe dass man halt
rastalocken dich eigentlich
züge oder durch große summen für uns zu
bekommen das mit arnika widerstand ist
für mich irgendwo wieder nachvollziehbar
mutter und kind gingen nach der
entlassung zurück in das missliche
umfeld aus dem sie kamen für die
betreuerin ist das nicht immer einfach
und wie war's das mit trinken was für
eine situation
rund 60 prozent aller inhaftierten
frauen sind mütter die meisten versuchen
ihrer mutterrolle trotz allem
auszufüllen
so auch btc die aus kamerun stammt und
in frankreich lebte als ihr jüngster
sohn 13 war kam sie wegen drogenhandels
für acht jahre ins gefängnis
ich habe drei kinder ein mädchen und
zwei jungen
ein zweiter enkel kommt bald zur welt
der erste ist sechs jahre alt
ich habe eine schwester die großartig
ist und die meine kinder zu sich
genommen hat
sie hilft mir diese prüfung die ich
durchlebe durchzustehen es tröstet mich
und hilft mir dabei die haft zu
überstehen
sie freut sich das neue video telefonie
erlaubt ist einmal im monat darf sie
jetzt ihre familie via skype sehen für
20 minuten sonst bleiben sie telefonisch
in kontakt
ich habe meine freiheit verloren aber
nicht mein recht mutter zu sein auch
wenn es nicht immer einfach ist
entscheide von ferne zu fällen mit der
unterstützung meiner schwester geht es
wenn sie etwas entscheidet gebe ich mein
einverständnis
andere frauen sind nicht in dieser lage
ihre kinder sind räumen platziert ich
habe das glück dass meine von der
familie um gibt
es habe keinen sinn zu hinterfragen ob
das strafmaß gerecht sei sagt sie
philosophisch
jeden sein gewissen wenn sie denken es
sei gerecht ich acht jahre einzusperren
für das was ich getan habe so dass sich
nicht für die familie da sein kann
müssen sie es mit ihrem gewissen
vereinbaren
ein einziges mal hat sie ihre kinder in
den letzten vier jahren gesehen die
reise aus frankreich ist zu teuer und
der abschiedsschmerz nach dem besuch war
zu groß
sports hat in hindelbank einen wichtigen
stellenwert
[Musik]
aggressionen abbauen und frauen
bereich gesperrt
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
es wird nachts über hindelbank es ist
halb neun um 9 werden die frauen in
ihren zellen eingeschlossen
sicherheitschef rené daten hat mit einer
betreuerin noch eine besprechung zwei
insassen haben sich gestritten
[Musik]
dass mir die konflikte scheut kein
hoschek das ist klar mikroben
[Musik]
genau
so
ein geschoss sprach
krise hat jetzt schon gespielt da
glaube ich
kann ich ja schon
heftig
plötzlichen
bringen
das ist
schlimm
gegner
haben frauen
eigentlich
gar nichts
isst
dann klingt das auge gegangen ist
nicht nur die betreuerinnen auch der
sicherheitschef geht nach hause er gibt
an die abend- und nachtdienste
meistens sind kleider oder es waren in
den papieren das ablaufdatum wird
kontrolliert abgelaufenes entsorgt
maximal zwei pakete pro monat sind
erlaubt damit nicht die einen viel
bekommen und andere nichts
unerlaubtes wird bis zum austritt der
frauen beiseite gelegt oder entsorgt
[Musik]
eigentlich kennt
nur drei angestellte bleiben die ganze
nacht an der longe im gesundheitsdienst
und im sicherheitsdienst
nicole schöne und er drogen und gehen
auf patrouille das
[Musik]
da ist das platzierung von der isolation
szene in der isolation befinden sich in
die maßnahme ist also sprich wo selbst
und fremd wartet sie bis
auf stellt er ja auch stadtzentren wo
sie nicht hat besorgte nach einer
hilfsaktion haben also die läufer nach
einer richtung am tag spazieren vorige
woche spazieren
das kontrollieren jetzt da dadurch
kontrollieren das nicht politisch also
von vw
mit la liga wenn die nachstellung nicht
das dauer haben durchaus stadt bringen
der drogen und kommt nur ab und zu zum
einsatz sonst wird ab und verzichtet
weil sie einschüchternd wirken und angst
machen können
maßnahmevollzug und freiheitsentzug sind
in hindelbank unter einem dach das heißt
auch psychisch kranke straftäter rinnen
leben hier
in der hochsicherheit werden frauen
untergebracht wenn sie für andere
gefährlich sind aber im moment ist
niemand in diesem gesonderten regime
allerdings werden die zellen gebraucht
weil das gefängnis voll ist
jedoch dann muss die frau wohl für den
stadtbus hate versehene tiere oft remis
öffentlich sagen diesmal und die
möglichkeit hier
stunden minuten und fitness betriebe
zurück auf der normalen wohngruppe
durchsucht der und den aufenthaltsraum
[Musik]
im frauengefängnis findet eher selten
etwas manchmal etwas cannabis
[Musik]
die pflegefachfrau ist ebenfalls nachts
unterwegs mit ihrem johnny verteilt sie
die medikamente für den nächsten tag auf
die wohngruppe
der gesundheitszustand der gefangenen
ist im schnitt schlechter als der der
bevölkerung draußen rund ein drittel hat
psychische probleme etwa ein drittel
eine suchterkrankung viele haben beides
das war's noch heftigere wege wovor der
ecke drin steht aber bis speziell was
sie
unterschrieben
das heißt
dass pro liter version ist eine gute
woche vor der nacht wach das geld floss
die ihr bau des öls oder rotkohl uhr
nachts ist das gefängnis ein
unheimlicher ort
auch wir das filmteam schlafen hier
[Musik]
erstmals haben wir nun eine idee davon
wie es sein muss wenn jeder neue morgen
nur der beginn eines weiteren tages in
der vollzugsanstalt ist
[Musik]
die direktorin ist nicht so nah an den
gefangenen wie die mitarbeitenden aber
sie begrüßt alle neuen persönliche
zusammenkunft mit ihnen aus neu
eingetretenen frauen und mit der
geschäftsleitung der anstalt hindelbank
der vielen dieser zusammenkunft ist dass
wir alle neu eingetretenen fahren einmal
sehen dass wir einen eindruck haben von
ihnen als person
ich komme aus brasilien hier ist es sehr
schön ich werde in biowares arbeiten
so etwas wie hier gibt es in brasilien
nicht darum bin ich sehr dankbar
alles wird der neuen genau erklärt damit
sie die regeln nachvollziehen können
denn von nun an können sie über ihr
leben nicht mehr frei bestimmen
es ist wichtig zu wissen dass das nichts
persönliches ist sondern das gesetz
sogar wenn sie ins spital müssen müssen
sie handschellen tragen
was wir von denen erwarten während sie
hier sind ist ihr
ausgehen dass sie wissen können es gibt
nie mehr passieren ich werde nicht
rückfällig werden ich habe neue
fähigkeiten gelernt
ich werbe draußen so leben können dass
ich nicht wieder zurückkehren muss nach
hinten ich glaube ganz schwierig ist
dass mehr mitwisser tipp zum schluss
drohte nicht also mehrheit mehr verliert
brown aus den augen sobald sie aus
breite sind da schon richtige sind wegen
der professionellen auftrag und
techniken fertig sind nicht privat die
beziehung endlich ist der nachteil dass
man die gene sowie die rück elliott und
wieder
heimisch zahlen wo man rund 20 prozent
frauen was sie sind sind wiederholt sie
die letzten jahr und da haben sie 80
prozent
da haben sie tatsächlich liebe erfüllen
die gefängnisinsel sind schon viele
jahre her die tiere haben keine
vorurteile
egal was die frauen verbrochen haben an
den eseln nehmen sich viele ein vorbild
sie fragen andere nicht nach ihren
delikt schließlich müssen sie im alltag
miteinander auskommen
[Musik]
einer der beiden ist mitglied im
inselrat müssen die insassen für jede wg
zwei wochen zusammenhocken
mitbürger monat reine frauen und der
gemeinde sechziger mit geschäftsleiter
diskutieren über das und probiere
gemeinsamen lösung zu finden damit es
klappt es ja im notfall ist
jetzt gerade letzte woche mit der
geschäftsleitung club diskutiert dass
die wofür stand ausgegangen dass man
damit
dass das geht
januar
freizeit ist
möglichst sinnvoll zu verbringen
[Musik]
münchen
107 frauen 107 geschichten der modernen
strafvollzug ist maßgeschneidert auf
jede einzelne
wie schnell sie freikommen hängt auch ab
von ihrer bereitschaft sich ihren
dämonen zu stellen
[Musik]
im gegensatz zu ihnen kann die
direktorin die anstalt jederzeit
verlassen
[Musik]
wir haben einen regentag erwischt als
wir anett keller beim wandern begleiten
es bietet sich an mit der ehemaligen
pfarrerin über schuld und sühne zu
philosophieren
und darüber was in ihrer macht liegt und
was eben nicht
jetzt in gedanken otto 100 wirtschaftet
und 100 liter und
astra leiter aber ja niemals irgendwie
einflussmöglichkeiten über alles alle
prägend mit und letztlich die ehefrauen
der großmacht bis wiederum sache mit dem
man selber machen oder mich und ich
begleite und unterstütze und fördere
konfrontieren aber letztlich machen
mainz die betroffenen selber
[Musik]